usually what they'll say in a problem
like this is will say that the
polynomial has rational coefficients and
what they mean by that is you're not
going to have any irrational
coefficients many square roots that you
know can't be simplified so if the roots
are two and four minus root two you
automatically know that four plus square
root of two is also going to be a root
so these are going to come as what they
call conjugate pairs okay and you can
see all I did was change a sign in
between these two quantities so again if
the coefficients are all rational these
will come as conjugate pairs so what you
want to do is you want to write it like
this you've got X minus the root okay is
going to be what they call a factor and
same thing here
X minus the root okay is going to be a
factor and then X minus this root is
going to be a factor okay but now what
we're gonna do is instead of writing it
like this let's go ahead and distribute
this negative so this is going to be X
minus four plus square root of two right
and this is going to be X minus four
minus square root of two okay so here
with me so far I'm just gonna bring down
the X minus two now what we're gonna do
next is we're gonna group the X minus
four is like this okay and I'll show you
why so what we're going to do is we're
going to multiply these together but
what happens is see these inner terms
here this is square root of two times X
minus four and then over here these
outer terms negative square root of two
times X minus four those have opposite
signs so they're gonna cancel one
another out so when we multiply these
together we're gonna get X minus four
times X minus four so that's X minus
four squared and then we're gonna get
square root of two times negative square
root of two which is just negative two
now let's go ahead and simplify this a
little bit further this is x squared
minus 8x plus 16 minus two okay which we
could really write this as plus fourteen
okay and we got it now we're just going
to bring down the X minus two and all
we're gonna do here is we're going to
distribute the X to all three of these
and the negative two to all three of
these so let's go ahead and do that so x
times each of these is going to give you
X cubed minus eight x squared plus 14 X
okay and then we distribute the negative
two we get negative two x squared plus
sixteen
- 28 if we add all those together you
can see we're getting X cubed minus 10x
squared + 28 X I'm sorry that's 30x okay
- 28
so there's your polynomial right there
so again the little shortcut technique
that I'm showing you here is remember X
- the roots is a factor but then what we
did is we distribute that negative and
then we regrouped these quantities in
such a way that you've got the same
thing the X - 4 and X - 4 and then what
we end up with is a sum and a difference
pattern so you probably remember when
you factored like a squared minus B
squared right how does that factor a
plus B a minus B and you can see the the
inner terms a B and the outer terms a
negative a B they cancel one another out
so it makes a calculations a lot quicker
and easier so let's look at another
example so example two here they're
telling us that the roots are 2 & 4 - I
so automatically if the coefficients are
real we know that 4 + I will also be a
root so if we want to write these
factors it's going to be X minus the
root X minus this root and then X minus
this root right
we do the same thing like we did on the
last example we're going to distribute
the negative so that's going to be X - 4
+ I and then same thing here X - 4 - I
so all I did is a distribute and I'm
gonna bring down the X - 2 so let's go
ahead and multiply these together and
the way we're going to do that is group
the X minus 4 is like so okay and so you
can see what's happening we've got first
terms X minus 4 times X minus 4 is X
minus 4 squared the inner terms and the
outer terms are going to cancel because
you have negative I times the square
root times X minus 4 and positive I
times X minus 4 those are opposite signs
they cancel one another out and then I
times negative I is negative I squared
okay which remember I squared is
negative 1 times a negative would make
this whole thing a positive one so now
we just have to foil this out that's
going to give you x squared minus 8x
plus 16 plus this one would give you 17
and then we're going to multiply by X
minus 2 and we're going to do the same
thing we're just going to distribute the
X and then distribute the negative 2 so
let's go ahead and do that
and then distribute the negative to that
gives us negative 2x squared plus 16x
minus 34 and if we combine like terms
you can see this is going to give us our
final polynomial and we've got you can
see all the coefficients the numbers in
front of the variables are real and
you've got it so again this is just a
reminder that you know when you have
these quantities that they come as
conjugate pairs okay and the other thing
is make sure that you do X minus the
root for your factor and then the
shortcut technique that I was sharing
with you is how you can rearrange these
terms in such a way that you have a sum
and difference pattern so that the inner
and the outer products are going to
cancel each other out so you just have
the first and the last and it makes the
calculation to go a little bit smoother
and quicker so I hope you benefited from
this video subscribe to the channel
check out more math videos on Mario's
math tutor and YouTube channel and I
look forward to seeing in future videos
I'll talk to you soon